- Ça fait que ça c'est la dinde.
- Merci.
- Line reçoit son panier de Noël
de la banque alimentaire de son
église. Et elle est loin d'être
la seule.
RICHARD CHOUINARD, pasteur,
Église de Rosemont
- Dès les débuts de la pandémie,
on a triplé le nombre
de bénéficiaires habituels.
- Des fruits, des légumes,
elle ne croyait jamais qu'un
jour elle devrait demander
de l'aide pour se nourrir.
LINE PAGEAU
- Quand tu gagnes des gros, gros
salaires et puis qu'un moment
donné, baf! Il y a séparation,
tu tombes sur le chômage.
Bon, là tu es monoparentale.
- Elle a épuisé ses économies.
La maladie l'empêche
de travailler. Elle bénéficie
depuis deux ans de l'aide de
dernier recours. Une réalité
difficile à accepter.
- Ah mon dieu! Ah, j'étais dans
mon auto puis pleurais. Je me
dis : si je rencontre quelqu'un
que je connais.
- Basculer dans la pauvreté est
une réalité maintenant pour bien
des familles à faible revenu.
VIRGINIE LARIVIÈRE, Collectif
pour un Québec sans pauvreté
- La crise du logement,
l'inflation, la pandémie, c'est
comme un espèce de cocktail qui
fait que ça fragilise des gens
qu'on pensait en dehors
de l'horizon de la pauvreté.
- Au Canada, c'est en
Saskatchewan et en Nouvelle-
Écosse que les taux de pauvreté
sont les plus élevés. Sans
compter les Territoires où
la situation est critique.
L'organnisme Canada Without
poverty craint qu'avec Omicron,
la situation se dégrade.
- Brocolie... 4 $ hier... check
s'il est beau.
- Parce qu'à l'épicerie, le prix
des denrées augmente, ce qui
inquiète Line.
- On va faire l'épicerie et on
en parle, le monde s'en parle
tous. C'est sûr que les gens
capotent.
- Avec ses petits enfants
qu'elle adore, Line demeure
philosophe.
- Aujourd'hui je mange,
aujourd'hui je peux partager
quelque chose. C'est ça. Demain
c'est une autre journée, mais il
n'en manquera pas, parce qu'il
arrive toujours ce qu'on a
besoin. Mais il faut y croire.
ICI Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada Montréal.   .c MS